- Hey guys, how's it going?
It's Justine.
And today I am so excited!
Before we get started,
this video is for charity.
What is inside this Xbox is something
that I created with my own two hands.
I'm so hyped to see what it looks like.
Xbox came to me and asked if I wanted
to design an Xbox for charity.
And they said hey we can
design it for you whatever.
Of course I was like, no I wanna do this!
I wanna do this myself.
I have a background in graphic design
so if you guys don't know that, I do.
I use to, basically that was my job.
I was a graphic designer,
in addition to doing video production,
and making websites and all of the things
that come along with that.
But, one of the most satisfying things
as a designer or a creator
is being able to design something
and then see it put into production.
So inside here is the Xbox
that I made with my own
two designing fingers.
I went in to Illustrator,
I found myself some sort
of generic camo background,
traced it,
and then placed each
piece of camo on this Xbox
where you'll see it.
So I guess if it looks
good, then it's my fault.
If it looks bad, it's also my fault.
But I think it's gonna look good.
I'll put a link in the description
if you guys want more
information on the charity.
There's a bunch of other Xboxes too,
so if this isn't quite your style.
Which I don't know why it wouldn't be
because I know it's gonna be fantastic.
I think The Rock has one.
Pulse Malone has one.
So go check those out.
Donate if you can.
I know that probably the donations
may end up getting a little but higher
than something that you would
ever want to pay for an Xbox.
If that's the case and you're a company,
get your company to
sponsor and get this Xbox
'cause I would love to raise
as much money as possible.
And a side note,
if it is a company that
ends up winning this,
and just to cover myself here,
if it is a company that I like,
something that I promote,
and it's nothing vulgar or inappropriate,
I will make a separate video
talking about this whole charity
and maybe doing some game play
and giving them a shout out.
With that being said,
I'm excited to get started and unbox this.
This is stressful.
It's seeing what you've done and made.
Oh!
I just spotted it!
I spotted it!
Here it is.
Oh man!
Let's get everything out.
I also designed the
controller too to match.
So, let's look at the controller first.
Oh my goodness!
Ah!
Can you even believe
how freakin' cool this is?
I put my little ij there.
I basically designed an Xbox
that I have always wanted.
Like this is exactly what I pictured
if I were to ever make an Xbox for myself.
Like this is what I would want.
So I'm hoping that somebody else out there
wants this as well.
Let's see what this looks like.
My eye's twitching because I'm so excited.
Do you
see
what I see.
Guys, this is it.
This is my Xbox that I made
with my very own two hands
and a computer and a
mouse and Illustrator.
It's so perfect!
The one on the auction
sight has a signature on it.
This one does not.
They made two of them.
So there's basically only two of these
in existence right now,
this one in my hands
and the one that is on the charity site.
You guys wanna check it
out, feel free to do so.
Check out my console.
Check out everyone else's.
I just wanted to make
this video super quick
because this is something that I love.
I love being able to help and give back
and this opportunity was
just really, really awesome.
A huge thank you to Xbox for
giving me this opportunity
and also partnering with Console For Kids
for making this whole
entire thing possible.
I think it's really great to see companies
and brands and people just get together
and try to raise money for good causes.
So, this is it!
This is the camo Xbox
that I've always wanted.
Again, the link in the description
if you wanna check it out.
And that's it.
What do you guys think?
Do you like it?
'Cause I love it.
(bright music)